[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct on est avec
vous c'est figaro live et on attend vos
points de vue face à la pression macron
peut-il résister doit-il au contraire
durcir le confinement
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur le
site du figaro depuis la mi journée et
je vous propose dans des matchs ce soir
avec jérôme jaffray bonsoir géraud bons
soins on rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et directeur du cecop est
avec vous ce soit avec nous alexis
brézet directeur des rédactions du
figaro bonsoir le figaro qui revenait
aujourd'hui également sur le rapport
rendu par le conseil scientifique au
sujet des régionales alors pour les
sages de ce conseil un report du scrutin
est souhaitable mais ce n'est pas eux
mais au gouvernement de prendre la
décision alors est ce raisonnable de se
poser ainsi ou bien est-ce se défausser
on vous pose la question on en débat
mais d'abord donc emmanuel macron
pourrait s'exprimer dans les prochaines
heures c'est en tout cas c'est
l'information
en tout cas une rumeur qui circule une
supposition qui sur qui circulent
vous pouvez lire en tout cas un article
une dépêche sur le sujet sur le site du
figaro au milieu de l'après-midi en tous
les cas vous étiez une légère majorité
même au début de cette émission une
majorité à répondre non non emmanuel
macron ne doit pas durcir le confinement
et c'est le point de vue notamment de
christian jacob
je pense que ça n'est pas la bonne la
bonne solution en revanche ce que je
vous dis c'est que je ne comprends pas
toujours le retard même si je pense que
les choses sont en train encore une fois
de s'améliorer sur la sur le taux de
vaccination ça n'est pas le cas encore
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas
en revanche plusieurs médecins à
plusieurs grands médecins demandent au
président de durcir les mesures à
commencer par l'un des plus radicaux
d'entre le professeur gilles pierre mais
les semaines qui se les semaines qui
vont se s'écouler là sont déjà écrites
pour des raisons de 2,2 d'histoire
naturelle c'était là que les gens qui
vont entrer en réanimation dans quinze
jours trois semaines sont déjà infectées
donc de toute façon quelle que soit la
décision politique
il y aura de toute façon ce ce mur dans
lequel on va on sait la réalité de cette
de cette de cette vague et de semur
surtout dans lequel on va jérôme est ce
qu'elle macron peut encore résister peut
tenir toujours sa ligne at il d'autre
choix que de céder à la pression
c'est en tout cas une énorme
responsabilité qui pèse sur ses épaules
un jeu n'est évidemment pas de réponse
claire parce que je ne suis pas
spécialiste des questions sanitaires
en revanche si on raisonne du point de
vue politique et du rapport aux français
du président de la république
c'est évident que c'est pour lui un
choix assez fondamental sur lequel il
joue en partie de l'appréciation qui se
reportait sur son mandat et donc partant
de là son éventuelle candidature en 2022
il ne faut pas se tromper
et de ce point de vue emmanuel macron
n'a pas toujours fait preuve je dirais
de la meilleure façon de
bâtir c'est de construire sa relation
avec l'opinion cette intervention de la
semaine dernière pour expliquer je ne
fais pas mon mea culpa tout ce que j'ai
fait c'était bien c'est ce que les
français ont compris
c'est à dire en fait j'ai bien fait de
ne pas confiné au 29 janvier était assez
étonnante parce que s'amorçait pas ce
qu'on lui demande
deuxièmement c'est être à l'opposé
d'angela merkel qui elle reconnaissait
des erreurs et ça renforçait une
certaine image d' arrogance de
satisfaction lui même qui agace beaucoup
les français
en plus on ne demande pas au président
de savoir si le 29 janvier il a bien
faut pas bien fait la question c'est de
savoir aujourd'hui ce qu'il doit faire
et ils adaptés à la situation du pays
répond t-il au problème correctement et
donc au lieu d'adopter un discours sur
le thème
voilà pour le moment nous naviguons mais
le cap toi tu est retenue c'est la
priorité aux sanitaires et nous
prendrons les mesures qu'il faut au
moment où il le faut le président s'est
un peu trop laissé aller à
l'autosatisfaction me semble-t-il avec 6
est ce que mails macron s'est-il aller
s'est il laissé les l'autosatisfaction
et maintenant poursuivre le raisonnement
jérôme hess qui doit résister est-ce
qu'il doit céder
gilles pialoux disait dans le même
interview dont on vient d'entendre un
extrait que les mesures de freinage
actuels n'ont aucun effet aucun intérêt
sans parler même des 41 médecins de
l'ap-hp qui brandissent la menace
maintenant du tri des balades sur
l'autre sidaction un oui évidemment il a
eu tort de donner le sentiment d'avoir
tout bien fait depuis le début en tout
domaine c'est évidemment faux on parlait
des masques des vaccins des tests du
confinement d'être assez aisé au lait
etc
il ya mille raisons qui permettent de
aux gens de penser qu'il n'a pas eu
raison sur tout mais il faut être
honnête en l'occurrence à questions
qu'on lui posait à laquelle il répond
c'est est ce que vous n'avez pas eu tort
de ne pas confiner le 25 janvier il dit
non je n'ai aucun regret j'ai eu
absolument raison la question s'était
quand même c'est la rumeur du politique
c'est y répondre quand il veut il
question lui est posée
je suis d'accord mais donc du coup on
coupe le morceau ou dans l'impression de
dire j'ai tout bien faire en fait il ne
le dit pas mais bon peu importe il ne
fallait pas s'exprimer comme ça
vu la sensibilité de l'opinion on ne
donne pas le sentiment de triomphe et
quand la situation est loin d'être
triomphaliste ça c'est le premier point
votre deuxième question qui est qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans les jours qui
viennent demain vraiment qu'est ce qu'il
va faire ce qui me frappe d'abord d'un
situation c'est qu'on a un véritable
rapport de force publique qui est en
train de s'établir aujourd'hui entre
d'un côté le président d'un public de
l'autre côté ce nombre de responsables
hospitaliers médecins responsables de
l'administration hospitalière
en gros tours 2-2 de l'ap-hp des
hôpitaux de paris qui sont tous ont
décidé de monter au front de façon très
coordonnée très volontaire avec notre
ère des tribunes un jour dans le jdd le
lendemain dans le monde des
interventions absolument encore donné la
division pour faire plier le président
d'un public tout cas il y peu alors
après on peut s'interroger
enfin ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils aient
tort ni qu'ils aient raison simplement
on a aujourd'hui alors que
traditionnellement on est dans l'est on
était dans les conseils que dans son de
médecins au bo politique est-ce qu'il
faut les entendre par exemple là c'est
plus des conseils
c'est un rapport de force et une
opposition frontale d'un certain nombre
de médecins et pas que de médecins parce
que autour de martin hirsch et pas que
des médecins c'est beaucoup
d'administrateurs administratif qui
disent il nous a pas écoutés le 29
janvier
maintenant il s'est trompé maintenant il
va falloir qu'il change et on va
finalement l'obligé en prenant l'opinion
à témoin avec des arguments qui peuvent
porter parce que dire aux gens comme ils
l'ont dit attention si on continue de ne
rien faire d si demain ou après demain
on va trier on va trier les malades y en
a qu'on laissera mourir
sous-entendu macron signes de progrès
d'ici on laisserait mourir des gens
c'est extrêmement violent extrêmement
brutales un peu gênant me semble-t-il du
point de vue de la façon de s'exprimer
c'est à dire que c'est quand même
utilisé la peur et l'émotion pour faire
pression sur le politique
mais n'empêche que maintenant macro il
doit faire face à ça et donc c'est pas
simple à gérer
après il a de son côté sans d'autres
médecins parce que les médecins ne sont
absolument pas unanimes on a par exemple
la fédération des hôpitaux publics
d'ile-de-france qui a dit mais non nous
on n'a pas du tout signé ce truc là on
nous a pas consultés on n'est pas
d'accord on n'a pas consulté les autres
médecins des infectiologues tous les mad
mats devront accueillir on ne fait pas
une tribune en disant qu'on va prier ça
n'est pas bien
patrick peloux très médiatique dit
grosso modo la même chose oui c'est
compliqué oui c'est tendu mais c'est pas
non plus il ya encore un peu de place on
va y arriver il faut simplement qu'on
compte tous les murs non on peut y
arriver
donc tous les médecins ne sont pas
d'accord donc de nombreuses parades eux
donc macron peut s'appuyer là dessus
mais au fond il a besoin aussi de
chiffres pour pouvoir dire vous voyez
les mesures qu'on a commencé à prendre à
quinze jours commencent à produire leurs
effets donc ça c'est des chiffres qui
vont arriver aujourd'hui demain ici peut
dire vous voyez ça plafonnent mon
sentiment c'est que lui son pari c'est
d'essayer de tenir le plus longtemps
possible en disant façon il ya les
vacances
il commence à faire beau il commence à
faire chaud donc si on tient encore huit
dix jours c'est bon
la question c'est peut-il tenir avec dix
jours sur ce que souligne alexis qui est
très important si on est entré dans une
sorte de duel entre mâcon et les
médecins car c'est comme cela que les
français reçoivent les propos allaient
la partie des médecins qui a qui
considère qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
s'affoler à ce moment là est beaucoup
moins entendu que la partie des médecins
qui dit risque des morts vous savez on
va dans quelques jours comptés cent
mille morts depuis le début en france ça
ça va faire très mal comme moment où on
sera arrivé aux 100 mille morts vous
avez l'idée du trick est hallucinant
dans la tête et une question je voulais
vous poser est ce que ça c'est pas un
épouvantail un spectre qui peut faire
basculer l'opinion bien sûr c'est à dire
l'image qu'on pourrait trier les
patients
l'image où vous auriez des ambulances
dans la cour des hôpitaux ou les malades
devraient être traités dans les
ambulante parce qu'il ne rentre pas dans
les lits l'image du tri sonderait des
images évidemment épouvantable un
professeur de médecine a déclaré ce
matin que d'ici quelques jours on
compterait six cents morts par jour
alors que nous sommes en moyenne à moins
de 300 c'est à dire que on est
effectivement dans une situation de se
battre fer entre les médecins et macro
me stupéfie l'erreur absolue pour macro
à ne pas commettre
c'est l'idée du parc et là je me permets
de dire de ce point de vue un lexique
quand ils se disent 8 10 jours et mon
pari sera gagné
c'est la notion de paris qui est pas qui
serait une erreur mortelle vis-à-vis des
français parce qu on ne parie pas sur la
santé la vie des gens on demande au
président de prendre les mesures de
protection sanitaire si elles sont
indispensables si en revanche
effectivement les hôpitaux arrive à
gérer même en y
de france la situation ce n'est plus un
pari c'est un raisonnement c'est quelque
chose de solide
donc attention chaque mois elle a une
importance extraordinaire le débat
public n'a pas prononcé ces observateurs
qui disent il a fait un pari c'est
généralement ses adversaires ils disent
qu'on parle de paris vont aller de pari
perdu et beaucoup de maquereaux nist
l'ont su utiliser en vie dans dix ans
pendant longtemps c'était d'impact son
pari du 29 janvier est un pari gagné
hallucinant propos la pause il avant pas
parler paris c'est un jeu c'est un choix
qui est fait en prenant en compte
plusieurs paramètres
il ya le paramètre de la déplace en
réanimation et ça c'est un point qui
mérite d'être débattue en rentrant dans
les détails
en regardant qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
malade en réanimation combien il y en a
en réalité est ce qu'on parle de
réalisation est ce qu'on parle de soins
intensifs à ce que tout ça est assez
compliquée et dès qu'on entre dans les
chiffres on se rend compte que c'est
quand même moins une claire que ce qu'on
voudrait parfois nous dira donc ça il
faut regarder ça de près donc ça c'est
un premier point mais y'a pas que ce
point là il ya mille autres points il ya
le coup dur confinement notamment le
coût économique on en a parlé mille fois
mais il est réel
le coût économique et des mêmes colossal
il ya le coût psychologique il ya le
coût pour les enfants parce que le
conflit n'est aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est fermer les écoles le l'unesco
vient de faire un rapport pour dire que
c'était une catastrophe pour les enfants
du dans tous les pays de tous les âges
mais notamment pour les plus petits
notamment pour les milieux les plus
modestes que de fermer les écoles
la cour des comptes vient faire rapport
pour dire qu'au fond l'enseignement à
distance ne fonctionnait pas ce que dit
jean michel blanquer
quand il prend il détourne un clip de
pink floyd pour dire sur toutes sortes
et nous débarrasser nous de
l'enseignement à distance mais c'est ça
que ça veut dire ça veut dire rien ne
remplace la relation entre un maître et
son élève
c'est la question de la santé mentale
c'est la question des suicides c'est la
question des jeunes ces mille sujets
qu'il faut prendre en compte
donc effectivement il ya la place si
l'action des places en réanimation
encore faut-il bien savoir où est-ce
qu'on en est et ensuite c'est mille
autres
ce qui me paraît pas pour parier mais
pour prendre une décision ce qui me
paraît pouvoir tout emporté c'est le
nombre de morts si le nombre de morts
augmente fortement dans les deux ou
trois semaines à venir
ça c'est un impact qui balaie tout le
reste
parce que la notion des vacances
scolaires nous arrivons en vacances de
pâques trois zones et c'est là il ya un
peu de jeu si le président décide par
exemple d'allonger la période des
vacances scolaires
est-ce que l'école est ce que les
enfants sont beaucoup plus contaminée
qu'il ne l'était il ya deux ou trois
mois avec le variant angles est et ce
qu'il transmet de cette contamination
beaucoup plus largement parce
qu'évidemment les enfants vivent avec
des adultes et ils les voient les
adultes ce sont des questions très
précises et c'est là où les
scientifiques sont attendus quand
j'entends par exemple les courtisans du
maquereau nisme venir expliquer que le
président est venu les meilleurs
quasiment là des meilleurs
épidémiologistes de france c'est nous
sommes dans le grotesque staline était
l'un des plus grands savants de son
époque
parmi les dirigeants soviétiques dans
tous les domaines c'était lui en fait
l'inventeur de la bombe atomique russe
de la bombe nucléaire russe 7 et staline
et ben macron n'est pas une meilleurs
épidémiologistes de france et il faut
éviter ce genre de nom mais il ne peut
pas non plus être le jouet d'un certain
nombre des pédiatres biologistes qui
parce qu'ils sont en situation parce que
c'est leur pouvoir parce que ils sont au
centre de tout envie parce que c'est
légitime c'est dans la nature humaine de
tout régenter donné des instructions
pour en politique la vie c'est pas les
politiques qui obéissent à des
épidémiologistes
il faut les écouter il faut voir ce
qu'ils ont à dire et voir ce qu'on peut
faire vous parliez le nombre de morts
c'est très intéressant si on regarde de
près les courbes on se rend compte que
les cours en réanimation augmente encore
faut-il voir ce qu'il ya dans les
ruminations les courbes de morte était
fort heureusement augmente assez peu
vous deviez 300 cc il faut se rappeler
que lors du premier conflit pendant
l'été dans les pires maux à 1001 donc la
croissance toujours trois centraux mais
c'est une relativement faible
augmentation par rapport au jour dernier
alors qu'henri à sa demande donc
pourquoi est-ce qu henry à sa demande et
que nombre de morts augmente beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup moins c'est un alors
cet indépendant qu'il faut regarder on
s'est probablement que ce sont des gens
plus jeunes et voilà qu'ils sont en
réanimation et qui résistent mieux aux
qu'ovide évolué sur lequel des
traitements en plus des faits des cas
c'est pourquoi il ya plus de gens plus
jeunes en réanimation parce que les gens
plus vieux
ayant été vaccinées ne sont plus malades
et on regarde on voit très bien dans les
courbes de réanimation qu'au dessus de
80 des cas de moins en moins de monde
donc on dit les gens sont plus en plus
jeunes mais ils sont statistiquement
plus jeunes parce qu'en fait les plus
vieux qui ont été vaccinés cette forte
heureux ne sont plus malades et donc ne
vont plus en rien et étant plus jeune
ils sont plus nombreux à être jeunes
dans l'erreur mais du coup ils meurent
moins parce que c'est en en travers et
on résiste mieux
donc c'est quand même des trucs qu'il
faut regarder de près et pas uniquement
dire à partir de demain on va dire toi
tu es vivant toi t'es mort moi je trouve
quelque chose de choquant et de gênant
dans cette cette campagne compte 10 à
maquereau voilà ce qu'il faut faire bien
sûr mais cette campagne qui consiste à
prendre en otage d'opinion à jouer sur
les peurs de me paraît gênante
alors c'est le cas l'avis également de
victor qui dit je suis choqué par cette
campagne de terrorisation menée par
certains médecins babineau internautes
fidèles du filao 10 mang lina gradation
des indicateurs ile-de-france et la
campagne vaccinale qui tourne au ralenti
mais neil mac rouler sous pression
jérôme est ce que l'opinion est ce que
les français peuvent regarder
indicateurs que vous avez accepté une
autre idée qui a été avancé par emmanuel
macron très vite qui est celle de vivre
avec le virus
vivre avec le virus on n'a guère le
choix 1 c'est ce que les français ont
découvert avec un peu de douleur c'est à
dire qu'ils ont cru un moment qu'on
était débarrassé du virus et qu'on
aurait pu ça maintenant la question
c'est jusqu'à quand devrons nous
deuxièmement vous avez un décalage assez
nette entre la vaccination et le
développement du variant c'est à dire
effectivement comme le dit alexis la
vaccination a pu toucher les plus âgés
neil 92% des personnes en ehpad sont
vaccinés c'est quand même l'un des rares
succès français qu'il faut quand même en
ligne la litanie
à l'époque il lors du pré confinement
tous les jours des quinze morts dans l
epad 20 morts ça c'est fini donc ça veut
dire qu'on a réussi quelque chose on a
réussi quelque chose et enfin et ayant
le souligne trop rarement
alors ce qui est vrai si vous voulez
c'est que les français sont partagés
quand on examine les études d'opinion
il y en a ras-le-bol le ras-le-bol qui
est évidemment beaucoup de français en
ont assez de ces restrictions de ces
fermetures de cette vie qui nous est
interdite en partie privé depuis plus
d'un an
et quand on regarde en même temps les
études ils n'hésitent pas à demander des
mesures fermes de confinement ils sont
assez sur cette ligne dans la majorité
de l'opinion
il considère que c'est nécessaire qu'il
faut le faire tout en individuellement
protestant contre l'idée qu'ils vont
avoir ça a subi c'est un peu comme les
impôts c'est à dire c'est quelque chose
qu'on déteste c'est quelque chose qui
est nécessaire ça n'est pas tout à fait
satisfaisant parce que l'opinion
publique du coup elle n'adhère pas
entièrement mesures qui sont prises dans
ces cas là elle l'est subit mais elle
n'en voit pas vraiment la nécessité et
du coup ça la place en décalage par
rapport au pouvoir c'est la rançon du
vivre avec ce qui en fait de bandes en
fin de compte du point de vue nature
humaine inspiration c'est que on
s'habitue à tout et que s'habitue en a
moins peur ayant moins peur on supporte
moins les contraintes car malgré tout si
on regarde par rapport à l'année
dernière
la l'adhésion en mesure de fermeture de
confinement aux restrictions de liberté
restent majoritaires mais maintenant
elle n'est que légèrement majoritaires
alors qu'il ya un an c'était du 90 % 95
% les gens voulaient tout fermé parce
que pourquoi parce qu'au bout d'un an ça
on en a marre mais dont on a moins peur
alors d'où d'ailleurs cette politique
cette campagne qui consiste à refaire
peur avec le nombre de places mais
mécaniquement quand on a vécu un an avec
quelque chose dont on s'habitue à tout
mais c'est quand même assez c'est ça le
vivre le vivre avec c'est d'avoir ma
peur est donc plus on vit avec moins on
a peur - en accepte les restrictions et
sa revente en plus compliqué d'autant
plus compliqué pour macron l'éventualité
d'un compliment parce que le risque est
qu'en plus les gens le noeud l'observent
pas on voit quand même de plus en plus
de gens qui disent oui c'est très bien
c'est très bien mais ils n'en font qu'à
leur tête on voit ça dans les
entreprises on verra dans la rue on voit
ça dans les trains voit partout les gens
n'en font qu'à leur tête et au fond en
ont assez alors bien sûr qu'il doit
durcir le confinement je comprends pas
qu'il ne prenne pas l'exemple sur
l'année passée nous dit jérémy deux mois
de confinement assez strict pour avoir
tout un été tranquille
surtout que pour les personnes qui
travaillent le télétravail est tout de
même de mieux en mieux développer
jacquelin qui n'a pas d'enfants dans les
pattes
jacques nous dit les chiffres de
contamination en ile-de-france sont plus
qu'inquiétants je crée en tout cas qu'il
n'est pas franchement le choix et
le lecteur qui est un internet du figaro
donc on espère qu'ils fassent le lecteur
qui soit le lecteur du figaro
stop avec on avait donc à vous
stop avec confinement ça suffit
assez de dégâts comme ça confie délai
dur ne pas fermer les frontières c'est
sans fin dénonce élan en tous les cas
c'est la question qu'on pose sur le site
du figaro vous continuer à y répondre
emmanuel macron doit-il durcir le
confinement est pour l'instant c'est
maintenant une légère
je recommande en faveur mais faveur du
oui il ya il ya un an lors du bruit
kaufmant les mêmes questionnaire sur
même site du figaro c'était toujours 4
entre 80 et 90%
oui donc ça veut dire que l'état
d'esprit a changé
je vois jérôme qui me demande si on
change de manger en mal animations et
elle est ravie d'avoir une recrue au
sérieux
c'est un point de vue non alors je vais
vous donner le la transition avec un
autre internaute qui s'appelle jacques
qui nous dit ne faut pas oublier que le
président n'a pas hésité depuis le début
de cette épidémie à se retrancher
derrière l'avis du conseil scientifique
merci jacques parce que ça nous offre la
transe la transition puisque c'est
l'autre question du jour elle porte sur
les régionales il incombe aux seules
autorités politiques de procéder en
toute légitimité démocratique aux
appréciations générales qui dépasse les
seuls aspects sanitaires ainsi qu'aux
arbitrages nécessaires qui sont
éminemment politique s'agissant de
l'organisation d'élections je vous
assure que ce n'est pas un communiqué du
quai d'orsay ce sont les termes utilisés
par le conseil scientifique pour refuser
de 2
pour refusé de demander un report des
régionales alors question vous la pose
sur twitter estimez vous que le conseil
scientifique se défausse en laissant au
gouvernement le soin de trancher sur un
report des régionales en attendant de
débattre justement de la réponse qui
majoritairement oui pour l'instant je
vous propose d'écouter d'abord olivier
faure il va falloir créer les conditions
pour ça puisse se tenir parce que je en
juin parce que il faut que la démocratie
puisse continuer à suivre son cours ce
serait le seul pays qui change qui
modifie son agenda électoral
ce serait là aussi un grave échec pour
le président moins tranché plus nuancé
le chef pardon moins tranché plus
nuancée roberge le point de christian
estrosi
lorsque je lis la liste des
recommandations qui jouit faite par le
conseil scientifique hier vote par
correspondance internet ne peut être
étalé sur plusieurs jours je me dis que
c'est très complet qu'aujourd'hui de
toute évidence c'est pas très
raisonnable de les maintenir à partir de
ce rapport du conseil scientifique qui
dit que si des conditions par rapport à
leurs recommandations ne sont pas
respectées il y à un danger alors alexis
est ce que le conseil scientifique a
failli ou bien est-ce qu'il est fidèle à
ce que doit être ce genre de structure
c'est à dire un organe finalement
consultatif j'essaie de répondre autant
cohérent il m'est arrivé plus d'une fois
de reprocher au procès scientifique de
prendre la place des politiques en
essayant d'imposer ses vues aux
responsables politiques
je vais pas là le leur reprocher de dire
c'est aux politiques de décider à les
vider à l'évidence y ont à l'évidence le
point de savoir s'il doit y avoir des
élections c'est pas un conseil
scientifique qui doit le décider c'est
et responsables politiques qui paraît
que le parlement va être associé
tant mieux ça me paraît très bien et
après c'est une responsabilité politique
de savoir si l'on tient les petits on
n'interrompt pas la démocratie
on peut pas confier ça à monsieur le
président qui au passage fait un
exercice du jésuitisme absolument
sublime en disant tout et le contraire
de tout comme souvent dans ces rapports
en disant si les autorités décident d'un
report des élections le risque de
consommation serait sensiblement
concours du mois de juin mais en même
temps s'il ya des nouveaux variants ça
pourrait être pire enfin bon bref on en
gros il dit et il se fait un malin
plaisir en disant après tout vous me
reprochez toujours décider voilà vous
avez qu'à décider vous même et la raison
c'est aussi aux politiques de décider
donc moi de là je c'est un procès que je
ne ferais pas pour une fois conseil
scientifique
jérôme comment vous analysez justement
le la vie et le rapport du conseil
scientifique magoudi je partage l'idée
qu'effectivement le conseil scientifique
en retourne son complément aux
politiques
les politiques disent oh là il ya le
problème sanitaire mais il faut tenir
compte de l'état économique de l'état
mental de l'état 2,6 de l'état zeit
cetera hélas le conseil scientifique du
bon bah nous avons loin de là ni
sanitaires mais il faut tenir compte du
point de vue démocratique du point de
vue politique
donc chacun renvoie la balle et là
monsieur delfraissy l'année dernière ils
avaient été entraînés dans la cour de la
place beauvau entre le premier ministre
était à l'époque edouard philippe
et le ministre de l'intérieur qui
n'était pas encore gérald darmanin pour
dire que c'était bien que les
municipales aient lieu le premier tour
des municipales aient lieu le dimanche
pas mon avis n'en a pas gardé le
meilleur souvenir du rôle qu'on lui
avait fait jouer et c'est aussi ce qu'il
renvoie dans cet avis l'air de dire ne
ferait pas jouer une deuxième fois le
rôle de celui qui dit maintenant la date
des élections c'est très bien ce qui me
frappe quand même c'est que globalement
la classe politique veut absolument
qu'on vote en juin alors que les
français eux se foutent pas mal de
savoir si on retarde la main mais si
c'est reporté en septembre ce sera pas
un problème pour eux l'ifop par exemple
dans son enquête mensuelle de match où l
on parle des sujets de conversation des
français il ya 18 sujets possibles
arrive en 18e place
les élections régionales dans les sujets
de conversation des vêtements on a posé
la question avec doxa
et françois fall dans le sondage qu'on
fait toutes les semaines dans le figaro
alors demandé ce qu'ils faisaient
d'accord avec un nouveau report 33% tout
à fait d'accord 38% plutôt d'accord 71 %
des gens qui sont d'accord pour reporter
les régionales
de ce point de vue les français sont pas
du tout en ligne avec l'étoile politique
elle y tient elle elle y tient pour
plusieurs raisons si vous voulez quand
on regarde les positions des différents
protagonistes la république en marche
plutôt ça ça s'annonce pas très bien
pour la république en marche vous fait
un scoop là pour les lecteurs du figaro
qui les internautes qui aiment la
politique c'est non ce pas bon donc
plutôt ça a lieu plus est loin de la
présidentielle plus ce sera oublié
c'est pas plus mal la droite elle a
besoin et régionales pour avancer sur
son dossier de la présidentielle car
d'abord il ya trois de ses candidats
potentiels qui sont des présidents de
région sortants
la comparaison de leur score sera un
élément d'information extraordinairement
important et donc d'ailleurs xavier
bertrand c'est pas un hasard s'il a
annoncé sa pré candidature
présidentielle c'est or ici un report
des régionales de ne pas me laisser le
mis de côté puisque il avait dit que
tout dépendrait de son score dans les
hauts de france est un parti de la
raison pour laquelle il a avancé les
choses comme il l'a fait et à gauche
c'est important de savoir par exemple
entre écologistes et socialistes qui est
en tête au sein de la gauche commence à
ce jeu pour savoir s'il peut se
construire une candidature commune
donc on voit bien que les protagonistes
politiques sont largement d'accord pour
dire il faut absolument voter en juin et
avec un argument simple alors le
président macron fait tout pour ne pas
confiné et il confierait la démocratie
ce serait extrêmement choquant
évidemment alors si macron pouvait
renvoyer les régionales après la
présidentielle et zaz c'est la kabylie
dans les régions lui devrait qui avait
sorti l'affairé dit c'est peut-être son
sous-sol son projet secret voilà donc
mais ça me paraît là pour le coup et que
ce serait très difficile et très
choquant car les élections
intermédiaires doivent rester des
élections intermédiaires et on doit donc
voter en france
je suis si c'est pas choquant que
on reporte les régionales et qu'elle se
tienne pas en juin est ce que l'opinion
penseraient que c'est choquant de les
reporter après les présidentielles ya ce
que c'est un point de vue de poly pardon
une politologue de journalistes
éventuellement de politique
écoutez les politiques et devaient y
aussi sur la démocratie c'est pas parce
que les français n'attachait pas
beaucoup d'importance à des élections
que nous ne devons pas tous
collectivement tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'action publique ne pas
dire que les élections c'est pas
important s'est prolongé le mandat des
présidents d'un nom comme ça d'abord je
pense que le conseil constitutionnel
pourrait donner son avis sur un tel
sujet logiquement et ce serait
extrêmement choquant me semble-t-il
mais je reconnais que les français ne
sortiront pas les barricades pour
défendre les élections régionales
donc oui les français ne sortiront pas
les fourches pour défendre les
régionales mais pour autant si un bond
aventure tous les partis politiques et
tous les journaux et on disait c'est un
scandale
mais maquereau en train de confisquer la
démocratie et c'est ça quand même pas
très bon pour macron il n'a pas non plus
avoir contre eux soit tout le monde y
compris son propre parti puisque en
marge du faux les tenir ça paraît
compliqué il ya un autre sujet pour
macro pour le mois de juin
c'est de ce dont il a besoin aujourd'hui
c'est de donner un espoir de dire la
crise elle va se finir y compris s'il
prend des mesures dans les deux jours
qui viennent de fermeture qui on
donnerait si elles existent ne seront
pas maximale ni très durement fin quoi
qu'il en soit il faudra qu'ils donnent
une une ouverture dire ça ça y est c'est
le dernier effort c'est le dernier coup
de rein on va y arriver la vaccination
va prendre le relais mais il peut pas
dire ça et dire au mois de juin on va
tout arrêter
c'est impossible et je vous dis voilà ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que l'été
fichu ça veut dire que ça va recommencer
à septembre tout pareil donc c'est très
compliqué je pense pour macron ça serait
très compliqué s'il en avait le désir ce
dont je suis pas sûr ça serait
aujourd'hui très compliqué pour macron
de reporter les régionales
et j'ajoute que l'exécutif est un peu
piégée dans cette affaire parce que vous
maintenez les élections au mois de juin
pour toutes sortes de raisons que nous
venons d'évoquer c'est une hypothèse
sérieuse mais si l'épidémie bat son
plein au mois de juin
vous êtes dans la situation d'un pouvoir
irresponsables incapables d'anticiper et
qui refait la bêtise des municipales de
l'année dernière
et si vous reporter à septembre d'une
part vous vous faites attraper pour des
raisons démocratiques
et si au mois de juin l'épidémie s'est
résorbé très largement
vous vous êtes a besoin en plus insulter
pour avoir reporté des régionales alors
que ce n'était pas nécessaire pour ça
donc c'est une situation assez redouté
d'atacama yvon les faits en juin après
avoir associé l'ensemble des partis les
avoir fait voter à l'assemblée que tout
le monde ait dit oui il faut qu'elle se
tienne comme ça si jamais ça tournait
mal et qui hélas l'épidémie repartent
mc on pourrait dire écoutez on était
tous d'accord vous allez pas me le
reprocher vous avez tous voté pour
l'heure maintenant alors et les parties
sont plus vicieux que vous nous avez
l'air de le sécher alexis brézet
aujourd'hui le réclame sur l'air des
lampions le maintien des régionales en
juin puis à l'assemblée ils
s'abstiendront sur la décision papale en
considérant que l'ird et le gouvernement
ne prend pas suffisamment de mesurer
quelles sont les mesures à prendre
le conseil scientifique pour le coup il
est là c'est précis une question je
voulais vous poser pardon je vous en
prie c'est que le conseil scientifique
regrette que l'exécutif et riffs réfusé
refusé l'idée d'un vote électronique on
a vote par correspondance il a tort il a
raison alors c'est un débat très large
et beaucoup plus compliqué ça très
difficile de mettre en place ce genre de
chose le vote par correspondance ne peut
pas fonctionner dans des scrutins où il
ya seulement huit jours entre les deux
tours parce que vous pouvez pas envoyé
le courrier et les professions de foi
des listes dans les délais voulus entre
les deux tours le vote électronique fait
perdre on voit que la dimension de
contrat social qu'il représente
en obligeant les électeurs allaient dans
les bureaux de vote en revanche le
conseil scientifique propose la
vaccination des membres des bureaux de
vote et ceux qui tiendront les bureaux
de vote doivent être vaccinés avant ça
c'est clair c'est précis des bureaux de
vote tenu en plein air pour des
élections fin juin c'est cet intéressant
comme idée c'est très justifier des
heures réservées aux publics les plus
fragiles qui n'auraient pas été vaccinés
éventuellement ça tout ça me paraît
parfaitement logique parfaitement
plausible il ya donc des mesures
sanitaires à prendre qui sont quand même
dans la vie du conseil scientifique
qu'est donc moins éthérée que ce que
nous avons dit un peu au début il
propose enfin il dit qu'il n'est pas
très prudent de tenir campagne
il dit tout le contraire de tout parce
qu'il dit enfin il veut pas entrer là
dedans donc le ridicule y aurait des
risques si à faire des réunions
publiques pendant les campagnes mais
qu'on peut trouver d'autres moyens de
faire campagne
bon oui bien sûr mais après sifflé par
exemple il faut ouvrir la télévisi
télévision régionale ou l'iss pendant un
temps c'est une des choses qui doivent
proposer par le gouvernement dans le
texte de maintien des élections au mois
de juin et qui ferait par exemple
puisque entre 19h et 20h les télévisions
régionales peuvent exister les listes
pourraient avoir un temps de parole
particulier pendant cette période dans
chaque région
voilà c'est ce genre de choses elles
vont faire écho aux élections régionales
les réunions publiques les meetings tous
a rappelé que ça n'a jamais non plus de
déplacer les foules et j'avais des
meetings monstres etc
c'est vrai que ce sera plus compliqué
ils font des choses en extérieur ils
font des marchés on se serrera pas la
main bon ça sera plus difficile mais en
même temps on peut pas arrêter la
démocratie il ya quand même pas un pays
au monde on arrête le démocratie partout
au début il ya un an ce nombre
d'élections est annulé mais depuis elles
se tiennent partout
imaginez par exemple que trump a
expliqué qu'on allait arrêter les
élections n'auraient pas dû plus ben
opel qu'il va pas vous mais qu'est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas dit on croyait pas
l'épidémie
mais enfin vous voyez donc on peut pas
arrêter la démocratie non plus les
régionales ne sont pas un problème nous
dit cet internaute si on peut aller au
supermarché on peut et même on doit
voter tous les autres pays nous dit
nicole ont organisé leur élection dont
pas de raisons de reporter chez nous
aujourd'hui on se prête on sait se
protéger poursuit-elle pendant un vote
masque j'ai le stylo donc rien à
craindre
et puis romain à cette suggestion un peu
perfide les sont votées des personnes
vaccinées à deux doses ça ira vite pour
le dépouillement section quand vous
posez sur twitter ceci le savoir si le
passeport sanitaire vos cartes et la
carte d'électeur carte d'électeur
estimez vous que le conseil scientifique
se défausse en laissant au gouvernement
le soin de trancher sur un report de
l'âge ionale vous répondez oui vous
n'aimez pas visiblement trop le conseil
scientifique est peut-être une
correction puisque je vois sur la
première question qu'on pose est tout à
l'heure sur le site
emmanuel macron doit-il durcir le
confinement est actuellement sur le site
c'est une majorité de non à 52 6 % new
effectivement c'est une c'est un débat
avoir été mené merci beaucoup
on se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit avec lyon requête à très vite
sur fear alive
[Musique]